نقلت الولايات المتحده في الاشهر الاخيره
مئات الالاف من قذائف المدفعيه من مخزونها
من الذخيره في اسرائيل الى اوكرانيا وفقا
ما كشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
الذخيره التي تم نقلها الى اوكرانيا كانت
جزءا من مخزون الاسلحه الامريكيه التي تم
تخزينها مسبقا في مستودعات في اسرائيل
كجزء من اتفاقيه بين الدولتين الصحيفه
الامريكيه اكدت ان هذه الخطوه هي جزء من
جهه كبير قام به البنتاجون لاعاده امداد
الجيش الاوكراني الذي يحتاج الى عشرات
الالاف من قباء في المدفعيه كل شهر لحربه
ضد روسيا التي تعتبر فيها نيران المدفعيه
عنصرا رئيسا اسرائيليون قالوا لموقع
اكسيوس ان البنتاجون اثار القضيه معه
مسارات الدفاع الاسرائيليه قبل نحو اربعه
اشهر واكد ان هذه الاخيره هي ملكه
للولايات المتحده ولا تحتاج الى اذن من
اسرائيل في المقابل مشاهدينا كشف مسؤول
اسرائيل بدون اخرون ان القلق الرئيسي وان
روسيا ستعتبر هذه الخطوه بمثابه مساعده
عسكريه من جانب اسرائيل لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]